I have spoken to um a lot of my
ex-boyfriends who I'm still really close
with and had those conversations of like
I'm sorry that I was such a partyer
while we were together that could not
have I love accountability that's so big
of you that's hard a lot of people don't
actually take that step have you ever
done that with anyone I have I feel like
I've held myself accountable and
forgiven where needed um I'm not friends
with all of my exes and by the way there
are some you need
close those chapters are you are you
friends with your I just went to my ex's
wedding and that was pretty exciting no
way how was that it was amazing it was
amazing I got immediately when I walked
in I had somebody say uh Nat Wolf the ex
an evolved man and then they all cheers
to me and somebody come they like are
you the ex yeah